most people  are looking at love as something they're  trying to extract from another human  being they're trying to get it they're  trying to fill some hole or some need  that they have and the idea being like i  will be complete when you know you  complete me like when i meet that  perfect mate and we're together then  everything is going to be great as  opposed to this idea of be love where  you're you're exuding it you're looking  to  contribute love and i just know for  myself like i have to practice  the habit of like how can i contribute  how can i you know exude my next  encounter with you know something  positive for that person but it's a  practice it's just like a muscle it's a  habit that i have to cultivate